so i do believe that ai systems
for them to integrate into human society
as it is now have to have a sense of
agency so there has to be a
individual
because otherwise we wouldn't relate to
them we could engage certain kinds of
individuals to make sense of them for us
and be almost like did you ever watch
star trek
uh like voyager like there's the volta
who are like the interfaces the
ambassadors for the dominion um we may
have ambassadors that speak on behalf of
these systems they're like the mentats
of dune maybe or something like this i
mean we already have this to some extent
if you look at the biggest
sort of i wouldn't say ai system but the
biggest cybernetic system in the world
is the financial markets it runs outside
of any individual's control and you have
an entire stack of people on wall street
wall street analysts to cnbc reporters
whatever they're all helping to
communicate what does this mean
you know like jim cramer like running
around yelling and stuff like all of
these people are part of that lowering
of the complexity there to
meet
sense you know to help do sense making
for people whatever capacity they're at
and i don't see this changing with ai
systems i think you would have ringside
commentators talking about all the stuff
that this ai system is trying to do over
here over here because it's a it's
actually a super intelligence so if you
want to talk about humans interfacing
making first contact with super
intelligence we're already there we do
it pretty poorly and if you look at the
gradient of power and money what happens
is the people closest to it will
absolutely exploit their distance
for
um personal financial gain
so
we should look at that and be like oh
well that's probably what the future
will look like as well
but um but nonetheless i mean we're
already doing this kind of thing so in
the future we can have ai systems but
you're still gonna have to trust people
to bridge the sense making gap to them
see i don't i just feel like there could
be of like millions of ai systems that
have
um have agencies you have when you say
one super intelligence superintelligence
in that context means
it's able to uh solve particular
problems extremely well but there's some
aspect of human-like intelligence that's
necessary to be integrated into human
society
so not financial markets not
sort of weather prediction systems or i
don't know logistics optimization i'm
more referring to things that you
interact with on the intellectual level
yeah and that i think requires there has
to be a backstory there has to be a
personality i believe it has to fear its
own mortality in a genuine way like
there has to be
all
many of the elements that we humans
experience that are fundamental to the
human condition because otherwise we
would not have a deep connection with it
but i don't think having a deep
connection with it is necessarily going
to stop us from building a thing that
has quite an alien intelligence aspect
um so another now the other kind of
alien intelligence on this planet is
octopuses or octopadies or whatever you
want to call them
octopi yeah there's a there's a little
controversy as to what the plural is i
guess but uh
an octopus
um
you know it really acts as a collective
intelligence of eight intelligent arms
right its arms have a tremendous amount
of neural density to them
and
i see
if we can build i mean just let's go
with what you're saying if we build a
singular intelligence that interfaces
with humans that has a sense of agency
so it can run the cybernetic loop and
develop its own theory of mind as well
as it's a theory of action all these i
agree with you that that's
the necessary components to build a real
intelligence right there's got to be
something at stake it's got to make a
decision it's got to then run the uta
loop okay so we build one of those well
if we can build one of those we'll
probably build 5 million of them so
build 5 million of them
and if their cognitive systems are
already digitized and already kind of
there we stick our antenna on each of
them bring it all back to a hive mind
that maybe doesn't make all the
individual decisions for them but treats
each one as almost like a neural
neuronal input of a much higher
bandwidth and fidelity going back to a
central system that is then able to
perceive
much broader
uh dynamics that we can't see in the
same way that phase array radar right
you think about how phased array radar
works it's just sensitivity
it's just radars and then it's
hypersensitivity and really great timing
between all of them and with a flat
array it's as good as a curved radar
dish right so with these things it's a
phased array of cybernetic systems
that'll give the centralized
intelligence
much much better
a much higher fidelity understanding of
what's actually happening in the
environment but the more power the more
understanding the central
super intelligence has
the dumber
the individual like fingers of this
intelligence are i think i think
necessarily
i don't see what has to be this argument
there has to be
the experience of the individual agent
has to have the full richness
of the human-like experience you have to
be able to be
driving the car in the rain listening to
bruce springsteen and all of a sudden
break out in tears because remembering
some something that happened to you in
high school we can implant those
memories if that's really needed but no
no no but the central agency like i
guess i'm saying for for in my view for
intelligence to be born you have to have
uh a decentralization
like each one has to struggle and reach
so each one
in excess of energy has to reach for
order as opposed to a central place
doing so have you ever read like some
sci-fi where um there's like hive minds
uh like the vern revenge i think has one
of these and then some of the stuff from
um
yes on the commonwealth saga the idea
that uh you're an individual but you're
connected with like a few other
individuals telepathically as well and
together you form a swarm
so if you are i need to ask you what do
you think it is the experience of if you
are like well a borg right if you are
one if you're part of this hive mind
outside of all the aesthetics forget the
aesthetics
internally what is your experience like
because i have a theory as to what that
looks like
the
one question i have for you about that
experience is
how much is there a feeling of freedom
of free will because i
obviously as a human very biased
but also somebody who values freedom and
biased it feels like the experience of
freedom is essential for
um
trying stuff out to being to being
creative and doing something truly novel
which is at the core of
yeah well i don't think you have to lose
any freedom when you're in that mode
because i think what happens is we think
we still think and i mean you're still
thinking about this in a sense of a
top-down command and control hierarchy
which is not what it has to be at all um
i think the experience so i'll just you
know
show my cards here i think the
experience of being a robot in that
robot swarm
a robot who has agency over their own
local environment that's doing sense
making and reporting it back to the hive
mind
um i think that robot's experience would
be
one of when the hive mind is working
well
it would be an experience of like
talking to god right that you
essentially are reporting
to
you're sort of saying here's what i see
i think this is what's going to happen
over here i'm going to go do this thing
because i think if i'm going to do this
this will make this change happen in the
environment
and and then and
god she may tell you
that's great and in fact your your
brothers and sisters will join you to
help make this go better right and then
she can let your brothers and sisters
know hey you know peter is going to go
do this thing would you like to help him
because we think that this will make
this thing go better and they'll say yes
we'll help him so the whole thing could
be actually a very emergent
the sense of you know what does it feel
like to be a cell in a network that is
alive that is generative and i think
actually the feeling is serendipity
that that there's random order not
random disorder or chaos but random
order just when you needed to hear bruce
springsteen you turn on the radio and
bam it's bruce springsteen right that
feeling of serendipity i feel like um
this is a bit of a flight of fancy but
every cell in your body
must have like what does it feel like to
be a cell in your body when it needs
sugar there's sugar when it's oxygen
there's just oxygen now when it needs to
go and do its work and pull like as one
of your muscle fibers right
it does its work
and it's great it contributes to the
cause right so this is all again a
flight of fancy but i think as we
extrapolate up what does it feel like to
be an independent individual with some
bounded sense of freedom all sense of
freedom is actually bounded but it
without a sense of freedom that still
lives within a network that has order to
it and i feel like it has to be a
feeling of serendipity so the cell
there's a feeling of serendipity even
though
it has no way of explaining why it's
getting oxygen and sugar when it gets it
so you have to each individual component
has to be
too dumb to understand the big picture
no the big picture's bigger than what it
can understand but isn't that an
essential characteristic of the
individual is to be too dumb
to understand the bigger picture like a
bit not necessarily but limited in its
capacity to understand because the mo
okay the moment you understand i feel
like that leads to
if you tell me now
that there's some bigger intelligence
controlling everything i do intelligence
broadly defined meaning like you know
even the sam harris thing there's no
free will
if i'm smart enough to truly understand
that that's the case
that's gonna i don't know if i have a
philosophical breakdown yeah right
because we're in the west and we're
pumped full of this stuff of like you
are
a golden fully free individual with all
your freedoms and all your liberties and
go grab a gun and shoot whatever you
want to no it's actually you don't
actually have a lot of these you're not
unconstrained but the areas where you
can
manifest agency
you're free to do those things you can
say whatever you want on this podcast
you can create a podcast right yeah
you're not i mean you have a lot of this
kind of freedom but even as you're doing
this you are actually i guess where the
the the demo of this is that
we are already intelligent agents
in such a system right in that one of
these these like robots of one of five
million little swarm robots or one of
the borg
they're just posting an internal
bulletin board i mean maybe the board
cube is just a giant facebook machine
floating in space and everyone's just
posting on there they're just posting
really fast
and like oh yeah it's called the
metaverse now the nest called the
metaverse that's right here's the
enterprise maybe we shall go shoot it
yeah everyone upvotes and they're going
to go shoot it right but we already are
part of a human
online collaborative environment and
collaborative sense making system it's
not very good yet it's got the overhangs
of zombie sense-making institutions all
over it but as that washes away and as
we get better at this
we are going to see humanity improving
at speeds that um are unthinkable in the
past and it's not because anyone's
freedoms were limited in fact the open
source when we started this with open
source software right the collaboration
what the internet surfaced was the
ability for people all over the world to
collaborate and produce some of the most
foundational software that's in use
today right that entire ecosystem was
created by collaborators all over the
place
so
these online kind of swarm kind of
things are not
novel it's just i'm just suggesting that
future ai systems if you can build one
smart system
you have no reason not to build multiple
if you build multiple there's no reason
not to integrate them all into a
collective sense making um substrate and
that thing will certainly have emergent
intelligence that none of the
individuals and probably not in the
human designers will be able to really
you know put a bow around and explain
but in some sense would that ai system
still be able to go
like rural texas buy a ranch go off the
grid go full survivalist
can you disconnect
from the hive mind
you may not want to
so to be ineffective
to be intelligent you have access to way
more intelligence capability if you're
plugged into five million other really
really smart cyborgs why would you leave
so like there's a word control that
comes to mind
so it doesn't it doesn't feel like
control like over over uh overbearing
control
it's it's just i think systems now this
is your point i mean look at look at how
much how uncomfortable you are with this
concept right i think systems that feel
like overbearing control will not
evolutionarily win out
i think systems that give their
individual elements the feeling of
serendipity and the feeling of agency
that that will
um
those systems will win but that's not to
say that there will not be emergent
higher level order on top of it
and that's the thing that's the
philosophical breakdown that we are
staring right at which is in the western
mind i think there's a very sharp
delineation
between explicit control
now cartesian like what is the vector
where is the position where is it going
it's completely deterministic
and
kind of this idea that things emerge
everything we see is the emergent
patterns of other things
and there is agency when there's extra
energy
you